Everybody!
Hey, guys!
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Whoa, Batman!
Today's the day.
We will be finishing Batman.
Finally.
Also, guys, I don't know if you guys noticed this, but do I
look a little different to you?
So for those who don't know, I have a... I was raised...
by a single parent, i.e.
I only have one.
Okay, not for real single.
I meant like this skin suit.
Okay, I have a mom and a dad, but for this skin suit, I only
have one mama.
I don't have a, I don't have a papa because my mama is my
papa.
So
This skin suit.
My mama is my papa.
So, uh, yesterday, yesterday my mama papa, uh, um, did a
little bit of some refurbishing for my skin suit because my
skin suit was very, very old.
So now, now if you guys follow me on Twitter, you might have
noticed I.
I posted a little picture on the Twitter because I can do
this now.
I can do this now.
It's so good!
Do it again, Tokyo!
Oh my god, do it again!
um so yeah i can also do this but like it's not as cool as
the other thing that's it's not as cool though it's not as
cool to be fair this is the coolest part i didn't thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you chargoons she's
perfect um but yes the skin suit got a little got a little
bit of an upgrade uh went to it we put in the machine to
clean it up a little bit um gave it a little bit it's not as
like you know it's not as old well it's still old but like
it's not as bad as before you know like when you get like
when you go to like the apple store and then you like buy
refurbished iphone that's basically me that's me right now
i'm i'm just a refurbished used iphone at the moment don't
worry um other news Other news, I got my play button today.
I got it today.
I still can't believe I named it Doki Bird, FPS VTuber, TTV,
Facebook, YouTube.
I can't believe...
Did you guys know you can name your play button anything?
And I was like, there's no way.
There's no way they would let me name my play button, Doki
Bird, FPS VTuber.
Because VTuber, TTV, YouTube, Facebook.
I saw it.
It was there.
It was actually there.
And I was like, holy shit, there is a way.
A fucking course.
My only play button I own.
And I had to name it the most fucking dumbass name I could
put on there.
Also, another, there's so many updates.
Oh my gosh, there's so many updates I have to give you guys.
Um, but I was talking to like, for those who aren't into
like the apex community stuff um for those who don't know
who nice wig is nice wig is like one of the uh main one of
the casters for like apex legends he's like a really
well-known content creator in apex and he actually did like
casting for like the japan's like uh jay like apex festival
like a couple like in japan like last week but um uh nice
wig and tempo uh tempo for uh he's like the manager for tsm
um and also organizes all the apex legend scrims uh in the
pro community anyway tempo and uh uh wig convinced me to
sign up for the challenger circuit for the algs so so the
besties are gonna be competing in algs challenger circuit i
think like next week which one we're joining but they were
like doki are you down for it and i was like you know what
fuck it i don't like we might get knocked out in the first
round but fuck it let's do it so i'm gonna be doing i'm
gonna be doing the challenger circuit with nice wig and
tempo like tempo was like doki no we can make it to the
semi-finals i was like okay i was just like tempo we're
gonna be
none of us script you watching scripts is not considered
screaming i have been busy trying to speed run restarting my
career right now like i i don't know what you mean if you
think that we're gonna make it to the semi-final like i i
don't know what you're talking about it'll be fun It's going
to be fun, but I do not think we're going to make it all the
way to the semi-finals.
Anyway, so I think it's like either next week or the week
after that.
We're just going to see what Wig's schedule is going to be
like, because it's all dependent on him, since he's like the
busy one out of the three of us.
I was also invited to the Apex invitation.
For those who don't know, there is a invitation, they just
recently announced the Nessie Cup Invitationals in NA, and I
was invited to participate in at least one of them, because,
well, to be fair, it's more so, I was like, tempo, can I
join?
And he's like, yeah.
So, like, that was basically how it went.
because I was like oh hey I just saw this can I join yeah
you can I was like sweet
so so I'm gonna be there too
um for and it's I don't even know if I'm gonna win any money
but it was like 25 000 or something I don't know it was like
wait let me see where if I could find the um let me see if I
could find like the details of it it's like something i just
saw it pop up on my twitter and i was like can i join yeah
you can i'm like cool yeah all right apex legends nesting
cup oh yeah yeah it's 25 what is it holy shit okay each
event wait it's 50 000 holy fuck okay apparently each event
is $50,000 prize pool.
It's like mini games too.
Which is the best part?
It's like, and there's like three of them.
So I asked if I could join like at least one of them.
So I wanted to do the mini games one because like there's
like hide and seek and stuff like that and like fisting,
like punching people out.
And I was like, I rather do the ones where I can like not
actually shoot my gun.
And that's fine with me.
because there's like there's like three different
invitations the second one is like where you actually have
to shoot your gun and play as a team but the first
invitational and the third invitational is like you get to
fuck around and you can you don't have to like actually
shoot your gun so i was like i would like to be in either of
those for that sweet 50k
to shoot my gun sign me up so yeah so those are like the
apex updates for uh for like for i don't when is the first
one again that one is on march 7th so i might be on the
march 7th one i'm not sure yeah i'm just waiting for i'm
just waiting for uh i'm just waiting for like to know which
one I'm going to be in but there's gonna be no it's a 50k
prize pool of course it's not per person what the fuck I
just like I feel like that it was like per person like I
feel like that money would be used instead to improve apex
more I do not think that they would be willing to give 50k
per person in a random tournament I'd rather have that money
be used in apex legends in general and just improve the game
Super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh boy, I sure am excited for the Facebook streams.
I mean, a say-so in your play button.
No one lies on the internet.
Of course not.
Don't worry.
I never said when.
I'll be streaming on Facebook.
Guess you just gotta wait until it happens.
But yeah, it's lots of fun little updates for all of us.
I know I wrote down some stuff too.
I was working the entire day.
Holy shit.
Oh my god It was a lot of A lot of work today But yes anyway
let's actually finish Batman I swear okay How many times you
guys think I'm gonna crash guys What Please I just want to
finish Batman That's all I want Let me finish Batman I love
I love I could do this now all right here we go
what you don't do you even have a and then the doctor slept
fine ever since Joker what is up with you and like breaking
people's legs Joker like at this point I think it's like a
fetish thing you're always breaking people's legs Broku,
thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, thank
you, hi Doki, it's my birthday today, and I'm glad I was
able to catch your streams, been watching your VODs for
around two years, and first recently started to watch you
live, I always enjoy your content, thank you, thank you, and
happy birthday to you, too, happy birthday to you, happy
birthday to you, happy birthday dear Broku, happy birthday
to you, alright, time to fist this plant, Oh, shit!
Get away!
Oh, okay.
Time to...
How the fuck?
Get away!
Alright.
Goodbye.
There's no cameras.
No witnesses.
Alright, where do I have to go?
Oh, the way there?
Can I...
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
I can get there.
Okay.
I gotta make sure.
I gotta make... Oh, wait.
Teeth!
Where's the teeth?
I hear teeth!
Oh, teeth.
Nice.
All right, here we go.
I don't...
I think, like, what?
Door's locked.
Is there another way?
Okay, thank God.
There's another way here.
I was going to be like, No, please don't make me go the long
way.
Please.
Is it supposed to be right outside?
What do you think you can do, Batman?
I am everywhere.
My babies know your every move.
I'm going to be so sad if she's not schooled.
Ow!
arrogant enough to think you could have Ow!
You will fail And we We will become the most powerful Force
on the planet Who's we?
You think the Joker Gives a fuck about you, Ivy?
He's always a solo act.
He barely gives a fuck about Harley.
He's always like Selling Harley off to the next guy.
You think you're gonna Be different, Ivy?
You're just delaying me I can fix her.
Oh.
Oh, she's talking about her and the plants.
Oh, that makes more sense.
Yeah, it's gonna be like, who the fuck is we?
Oh.
I'll make sure I fist every plant around me.
The other sniper, I'm gonna pretend, if I don't look at the
other sniper, he doesn't exist.
If you don't acknowledge the problem, it'll eventually go
away, right?
You will pay Batman for hurting my babies.
What if they're into this thing?
When I finish with Batman, I'll be coming after you, Joker.
Will you really?
Oh, that's gratitude.
You give him presents, experimental- Whoa!
Whoa!
Joker!
Ow.
Where the fuck shot?
Who's shooting me?
Oh, above.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Whoa!
Joker!
Ow!
Who, ow!
I salute my fallen enemy!
Oh, my God.
I supposed to know no okay at least I get to fist these
plants again you will pay Batman for hurting my babies when
I finish with Batman I'll be coming after you there's no
waiting I can't grapple there's too many people talking
presence experimental chemicals and nice costumes and they
All right, I still hit him.
It's gonna be like, I miss.
Where?
Where, no!
If I keep running, you can't catch me!
I'll just keep dodging.
I have no stamina.
It's 2010!
Ow.
It's okay.
We can hack this.
All right.
It's 2010.
There's no stamina in this game.
I can dodge forever.
Look, how the fuck do I?
I need to remember how to hack again.
Please.
Where's the green?
Oh, there it is.
I really don't want...
I'm too lazy to walk around.
Ooh.
Interview tape.
Tape page and interview 20.
Scared?
Yes, scared.
There's obviously something.
Something that made you what you are.
What if...
What if I'm too scared?
No!
Don't make him trauma dump!
You're gonna fall in love!
No!
Don't you remember what happened to Harley?
The moment he starts trauma dumping, it's over!
It's so fucking over!
I wonder if there's anything at the...
Oh, can I scan this?
No, I can scan this.
I thought there would be something here.
Wait, how do I get inside here?
You're gonna...
You're gonna be like, I can fix him!
And it'll be over!
It'll be over for you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So that's how it works.
Red Pixel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Congrats on the play button.
I wonder if it's possible that the name take up the entire
width of the plaque for the next one.
I don't know.
If I ever get a million, I'm just, like, thinking if I
should, like, if I should add more to it or just do Doki
Bird.
I was like, do I, I mean, the best thing about it is that
you can technically, you can buy, like, unlimited play
buttons.
It's, like, around, like, a hundred.
I remember it was, like, it was, like, I remember the Aston
about it before it was like two hundred dollars i think you
can buy like unlimited play button so it's not like they
said they send you the first one for free and then they um
and then the the rest you can you can pay for extra copies
so i'm just like do i actually get a real one do i keep I
keep adding more to it.
Let's see.
Can I go over?
It's me.
I mean, good for you for the photosynthesis.
I mean, we need more trees for oxygen.
So, like, good on you, Ivy.
Good on you.
Oh, hey.
Need that, actually.
New brick.
metal and paint covered old wounds fresh blood was injected
into the body bright new minds came and all swore to uphold
our promises we all knew we were the ones to fix this city
and the city would thank us and tom thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you so you're saying if we super chat
you $200, we can request a new play button for your
collection.
Um, like, in theory, yes, in theory, I could, if you, if you
like, you know, super chat me $200, in theory, I could order
a play button if I wanted to.
I could technically just decorate an entire wall with just
like silver play buttons that you've like sent me money to
buy for in theory yes chat personalized play button because
the thing is the reason why they do this is because like if
your channel is owned by like multiple people so you can
like buy more play buttons for the rest of the people in
your like youtube team so in theory i could be like you guys
are part of my x amount of play buttons and just name it
just name it in with whatever suggestions you give me and
just order like i don't know like 20 of them of different
fucking names yes in theory we could do this but the best
thing about this is that this is all theoretical
Stephen towards the play button thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you
Yes, this is all theoretical, guys.
It is possible.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, you know what to do, boys.
Play button, don't go.
Thank you for the super chat, still.
Thank you, thank you.
And that's a play button theory.
Not gonna lie, I'm pretty sure the...
What was it called?
The Game Theory channel is gonna die the moment he...
The moment he...
the moment he like leaves the channel for good uh thank you
for the akasuva play button is fun here it says thank you
for the akasuva thank you thank you i'm all for the
theoretical play okay how about this do you guys want me to
do you okay all right i'll let you guys name i'll buy I'll
purchase an extra play button and I'll let I'll let you I
like how I'm saying all this while like I'm slowly killing
Ivy And she's like crying about nature and I'm like play
button.
Let's talk about play buttons anyway I'll let you guys name
one play button
Do you think you can handle me I don't know if I want to buy
like 20 play buttons Whoa.
I'm waiting in here.
Come to me.
Whoa.
Trying to promise me a good time, Ivy.
Damn.
That's such a thick.
Okay, let me fly over real fast.
Oh, give me a sec.
Just gotta fist this one, too.
It's just...
a theory just a joke unless thank you for the super chat uh
black deer thank you thank you i vote for the name next
thank you thank you for the thank you thank you all right
okay how about this we're gonna make a community post oh
shit are they like did it get poison ivy whoa what about
harley It's okay.
We won't be killing anybody.
You can buy a punch and make a throne out of them.
Lord Pagik, thank you for the Aka Aka soup.
Thank you.
All right.
I think it's like this way.
Yeah, it's this way.
All right.
We will make a community post after this stream for all you
guys to suggest the names and then i'll make a poll for you
guys to to one the the jokie bird fps vtuber ttv youtube um
facebook is my play button and then i'll order another one
for the dragoons so you guys get a play button too and you
guys get to decide you guys will fight for the name you one
Because technically Dragoons are part of the team.
Because I couldn't have got 100k without you guys.
I won't let you destroy it, Batman.
Wait, she's not swole!
What's the point?
Now I realize they were evolving.
Growing stronger.
What's the point if she's not swole?
Why doesn't the Bane Juice make her swole?
Holy fuck, what?
This looks so wrong.
Okay, I don't know how to...
What do I do?
What the fuck do I do?
Oh, God.
What do I do?
Batarang?
Okay.
Is it Batarang time?
Batarang.
Oh, shit, it is Baderang!
Baderang!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's Baderang.
Oh, it's the Baderang.
Okay, open your mouth, Ivy.
Baderang!
Wait, I can do two Baderangs.
Whoa.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Baderang!
Ow.
Okay, only one Baderang, apparently.
I can only do one Baderang at a time.
The four...
Acting what about the voice acting can you please?
Please give me the details of what you mean by that.
Yes, I'm calling you out.
Fuck.
I don't I didn't see your name But whoever said that I'm
calling you out right now.
What do you mean by that?
All right, very good voice acting
It's just very good voice acting she was clearly doing so
well like that's what I mean
Exactly what he means Yeah, thank you for the super chat
Thank you, thank you Nice God boss fight is Ivy, come on You
got the bang juice You should be stronger than this
Alright, nice We just gotta run Thank God for like You know
what, I'm gonna say it I'm gonna say it Fuck Souls genre for
making Samina a thing.
I'm gonna say it.
Not every game has to be Souls-like.
Sometimes I don't, I want to be able to run forever.
Okay, battering.
Nice.
Alright, and also realism.
Fuck the realism shit.
I'm trying to play a man that's wearing fucking underwear
outside of his regular suit.
There's no realism to this.
Alright, she's like one hit.
She's loud.
Okay, who wants me to tone this down?
all right let me i want fun not reality exactly all right
it's fine i'm winning i win yay
i just hello oh explosives gel okay all right get out i'm
gonna tag your i'm gonna autograph your your plant it's mine
now now it's my plant we have to keep going wait it isn't
over what do you mean it's not over oh oh oh oh i thought it
was that easy no wait i can upgrade okay let's just upgrade
our heels while we're here i mean we might as well upgrade
our heels we might we might as well Nice.
He's trying to hurt me.
Oh fuck, okay, get out of here.
All right, get out of here, guide.
Please, there's other women!
There's so many choices!
My blads will carry you and your precious god over shreds.
Wait, what?
Okay, Han, no!
No, why did you shot your fucking batter abs?
Fuck, okay, that's not good.
ready for run, dude.
Alright.
Batarang.
God damn it.
I got hit.
Batarang.
I want to do this.
No!
Oh, okay, okay.
I thought I accidentally...
No!
I keep running to it.
God damn it.
I keep accidentally running into obstacles.
Alright.
Out.
Get out.
Batarang.
No, not Oh, okay.
Oh, thank God.
There's friendly fire.
Thank God.
Plast can't see which one's the real Batman.
Boop.
Concussion.
We're okay.
Jokey Bird confirmed hate environment activist.
Hey, hey.
I was president of my environmental club.
I don't know how I became president, but like, I was But
thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Tom.
Look, it's, it's still, it was still, it was still in my
college application, so it counts.
You know, like, I was that type of Asian that basically
signed up for anything, for, like, everything, so I can,
like, boost up my college application.
Like, you might not believe.
I want to save the environment.
The environment is very, very important.
But, like, you know, you're not like, like, you know, the
environmental person.
You know, I cared about the environment, but not to the
extent where I should have been the president.
It just looked really good on my college applications.
Also, uh...
Andreos, thank you for that vibe.
Give the shows.
Thank you.
I cared enough.
Yes, that's better.
I cared enough about the environment.
Okay.
Where's the worth it in the end?
I mean, I got to college.
And then I became a V-tuber and didn't use my degree for
this.
So, like, yeah.
Hey, hey.
It was Canadian college.
So, it's, you know, so, like, the tuition fee.
was not as bad as American college.
Alright, like, at least it was Canadian college.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Kick his ass for Ivy!
Okay, please, please.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Alright, it's alright.
Just friendly fire.
Alright.
Thank God for friendly fire.
Well, get out.
Oh, God, I need to get out of here.
Friendly fire, friendly fire Okay, I'll get rid of these
guys Because apparently it won't stop unless I kill all
these Sorry Just make sure they're just You know, barely
alive because Batman doesn't kill Alright, nice Well, you
got back up Don't worry, I'm pretty sure Ivy will pay for
your family Oh, this way Alright, here we go So close All
right, I think I need two more hits.
Come on, open the mouth.
Open the plant mouth.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, one hit, one hit, one hit, one hit, one hit, one hit.
Oh, God, I'm one hit.
She's one hit.
Rest it.
Easy.
All right, I'm gonna bang see your plant real quick.
Please be the last one.
That's my signature.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Canadian college fun
Bro, this voice acting Oh my god I'm just like thinking
about how you know like when you're voice acting you have to
give like A reel of like different like groans and stuff
like you're getting hit give me like 30 seconds of that
I did it, Joker!
Oh,
she got another upgrade.
Alright, let's upgrade.
We have...
Oh.
No!
Don't...
Okay, okay.
At least it crashed after.
At least it's after.
That's all that matters.
It crashed after the fight.
Oh, thank God.
I was going to be so sad.
Thank God it wasn't in the middle of the Ivy fight.
Oh, thank God.
All right.
It should have saved.
We just had to listen to Joker talk again.
That's okay.
All right.
It's all right.
We're almost there.
We're almost at the finale.
We just need...
We just have one more boss left, apparently.
Alright, let's go.
I forgot what I was talking about.
Alright, here we go.
The crash.
My biggest boss.
Ta-da!
That's me!
Where'd I go?
Okay, I have to wait until he tells us me what to do for
me whoa sounds so fun joker all right we gotta go to the
party oh my god i got invited to a party all right there's
really nothing else to upgrade now right his powers that was
easier wait i could have made this easier for myself Out of
reach and open up access that would otherwise wait I could
have I could have made this easier
Oh but guys what a three batter guys why didn't you tell me
guys you know I don't read
You know I don't fucking read I was expecting you guys to
help me to the best upgrades But, but Doki, two is, three is
better than two.
Guys, we don't need more batarangs.
We don't need more batarangs.
Fine, we'll have more batarangs.
Fine.
Three is better than two.
All right, where do I go?
Where the fuck's the party?
Three are right.
Guys, we could have made the hacking easier.
What do you mean?
I mean...
I would have struggled so hard trying to hack.
Does someone say more, Batarans?
I swear to fucking God.
Alright, let's get these guys out of here.
Alright.
Well, it's not really...
It can't have more brain damage, right?
They're already lost causes, I feel like.
Unless Batman, you know, starts funding the medical...
In the city?
I still can't believe Batman was Big Pharma this entire
time.
No wonder everybody's crazy here.
This is how he makes his money.
But the TV is joking.
What's that?
What's going on over there?
What is that?
What does that say?
Monster cell?
Oh my god!
This is it!
Hey guys.
If your name's not on the list, you ain't going in.
But it's me, Batman!
Let's see, yeah, A, no it's not right.
B, B, Bane.
Ah, here it is.
That's right, I should get VIP right now.
Hey!
I'm the guest of honor?
Give him a big Welcome, guys.
It's me.
I'm special.
Yay!
Oh, my God!
Guys, how do you know it's my birthday?
Because every day is my birthday.
Yay!
Happy birthday to me.
What?
Where's the birthdays?
Hello?
Birthday?
Are you excited, Max?
Yeah?
I mean, we've been building up to this point all night.
Don't tell me you've not been looking forward to it.
I know I have.
Where's the cake?
Oh!
Everyone always said I should be in television.
You don't want to miss this.
Really?
It'll be a blast.
Oh my god, you were here this entire time?
Nine.
8 Wait, where are you going?
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Oh, oh!
Is that a bomb?
Oh hey, I like how the blast put me closer to the room.
It like sucked me back in.
why didn't you stop batman me it was your plan you goofy
clown i know i know how did the bomb explode me closer to
the window it's like a black hole i'm sending you back to
the ventriloquist where you belong oh shit wait is that a
guard you had to spoil everything didn't you beating up bane
feeding scarecrow to whoa whoa joker it's over joker over
why my dear delusional dark night it hasn't even begun
joker damn
The saddest thing is you know Harley would pay for it too.
That's like the saddest thing.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
All right, that's fine.
We will...
We'll get on top of this guy.
Oh, God, oh, God, no!
Fuck!
Oh, get away from me, get away from me!
That's all right, there's friendly...
I...
Please...
Please, game.
Please, we were so...
Please!
Please, let me out!
Let me out!
I just want to beat the Batman.
I just want to beat Batman.
Perfectly optimized game.
Guys, it can't mostly be my PC is also because this game is
very old and the older games are rarely ever optimized for
newer PCs.
Guys, look, my PC might be a tomato, but like, you can't
fully blame it on my PC.
This game needs a remake?
I don't know.
I don't trust remakes anymore.
Unless, I mean, like, Dead Space is like one of the rare
remakes.
Remakes that actually, like, ow.
Oh, okay, that didn't hit me.
That's great.
Dead Space is, like, one of the rare, rare remakes that,
like, are actually, they actually...
Oh, nice!
He's better at bullying than me.
Oh, fuck, okay.
They already got a remake?
This is the Game of the Year version.
Wait, when did they get a remake?
Wait.
All right, nice.
Got it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, fuck.
This will hurt.
They're lying.
Console only.
God damn it.
It's always console only.
Too lazy to play this on console.
Why can't everything be on Steam?
Dude, fuck console exclusives, man.
I hate console exclusives so much.
There's no point!
There's no fucking point!
Oling!
Console exclusive is fucking stupid, I'm gonna say it.
Because eventually, nothing is ever console exclusive.
Eventually, everything comes back to Steam.
Wow, Alex, you're very hurtful.
Everything eventually gets on Steam.
There's no such thing as console exclusive.
all the bait it's all the fucking bait except for nintendo
switch stuff because like it's harder to like port things
from the switch to pc all right nice i'm just gonna use
these guys as bowling for a little bit all right nice thank
god for bowling except bloodborne i feel like eventually
bloodborne will get ported to seem it's just Just like, it
just takes like...
Uh...
I feel like there has to be like some fucking contract right
now that's restricting it from hoarding it.
But I feel like eventually it's gonna happen.
Okay, nice.
Woo!
Oh, get away!
Get over here!
Nice.
It's time to...
It's time to slap them.
It's time to slap your friends.
That's fucking right.
It's been a decade.
I mean, eventually contracts run out, right?
Right, guys?
I feel like we're gonna see, like, a remake of Blood...
Maybe a remaster or a remake of Bloodborne on Steam or some
shit.
Get the fuck away from me!
Woo!
Leave me alone!
all right
come on please please kill the rest of the henchmen there's
like three left just kill the henchmen throw them okay okay
wait wait no how do you miss you're not me how do you miss
nice okay all right slam on the wall ow oh no yes all right
good I can slap them I can slap them now.
Wait.
How did all these guys keep?
Wait a minute.
Where did all of these guys come from?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my leg!
My leg!
Where did they come from?
They spawned.
indefinitely no no the last time you said that it wasn't
true there's no way the last time you said that that wasn't
true not joking this time no joking this time is for real
okay nice okay it's fine we're gonna have to head over to
this guy okay i almost got one down that's almost close one
down i'm trying there's so many henchmans no my leg god damn
it batman okay nice oh i'm like one hp i'm like one hp right
now Please.
Please run over to me.
No, don't pick up the body.
All right, I can dodge this.
Oh, well, I guess I'm not going to be dodging anything.
Oh, nice to dodge it.
Thank God.
Woo!
Okay, I can punch him.
No.
Oh, all right, one guy left.
One guy.
No!
Please!
Yes!
Oh, we got one of them.
Okay, we just gotta leave.
Okay, this will be easier now.
Now that there's one, it'll be easier.
It should be easier, theoretically.
Theoretically, it should be easier.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Come on.
Come on, just...
Just run.
Yes!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Oh, thank God!
One HP in a dream!
Nice.
Oh, shit!
I thought it was over.
I almost could have died.
Nicely done, bats.
You deserve a prize.
Your old pal, Commissioner Gordon.
Gordon?
Say, he looks all run down.
What happened, Gordon?
Wait, what?
Oh!
what do you do what is this oh my god i'm gonna bane out
here we go you're trying to resist the change that's not oh
come on get in
no his pure body that's definitely not oh natural How am I
gonna join the Olympics now Joker?
My big night!
Months of planning down the crapper.
I just wanted to bring down your grim facade and for once
let you see the world as I see it.
Giggling in a corner and bleeding.
But you've denied me even that.
I have nothing to live for.
Oh shit!
That's actually scary.
Joker on Venom Juice.
Thank you, thank you for the fire, get the shares, thank
you, thank you.
Thank you.
Just 10 minutes ago, we received this taped message.
Greetings, Gotham.
Joker.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Wait, the Olympics are all clean?
It's way...
Whoa!
You should...
That's what you say.
You whispered that.
I like how... I like how the bane juice makes him have a
mohawk as if it affects his fucking hair.
That's for inside voices, not outside voices.
something to talk about what the fuck oh look he gets to
keep his underwear too
i feel like the one thing that should have been like ripped
open is the underwear and pants oh
no joker this body is all natural I don't need no I don't
need performance enhancements but
you still spoil my fun and for that I'll paint Arkham with
your blood let's get ready what the fuck is wrong with your
nails holy shit Joker cut your nails that's so uncomfortable
ow Alright, how the fuck do I kill you?
Do I throw batterangs at you?
Wait, this is the worst...
Please, we're so close.
Please, please, we're so close.
We're so close!
Junker, please!
oh my god how did my crashes get worse that's like the one
thing i don't understand it's like every time i boot up this
game every like the more days i pass the worse the crashes
get like how did it get worse oh my god please we're so
close we're like literally in the finish line it's like
please please all right here we go it's all right it's like
i never got slapped in the first place whoop whoop ow what
the fuck how do i get away from that all right excuse me
that's bob choker is too strong what do you do all right i
mean these guys are easy to beat as long as they're not the
tanky ones.
That's fine.
I'm fine if they're not the super tanky ones.
Wait, there's presents!
For me?
Okay, throw.
Nice.
That's fine.
I can literally just X everything.
X, X, X, and then Y.
Gosh, no!
It's never good to counter!
There's never a good time to counter!
Oh shit.
How do I get rid of this?
How to get rid of teeth.
Teeth.
Get away from me, teeth.
Alright, nice.
I just need to help the other one.
Use the middle stick to avoid the crashes.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Now I can just why everything.
Nope, never mind.
God damn.
What?
Whoa, what's going on?
What the fuck happened?
Whoa.
Oh my god.
What the fuck happened?
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
That's fucking up my PC.
That man's like fucking up my PC.
My PC is like, please, please beat Batman.
Please...
Holy shit!
Please beat Batman, we need you to beat Batman!
Oh my god!
Bro, my fucking thing is freaking out right now!
Everything... Everything is freaking out!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
I don't know.
I don't know if it's okay.
Please get me out of this hell hole.
Get me out.
Ow!
Oh shit.
Please.
Let me kill Batman.
I'm not Batman.
Let me kill Joker.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's more?
I think if you're not with me.
Oh, God.
Am I back in it?
Use your imagination.
Bro, we're in the back!
Oh,
shit.
Where am I?
Oh, my God.
Give me a sec.
It's a journey right now.
It's a journey.
Holy shit.
It's okay.
here it's okay we're almost back guys i just need you guys
to know my obs window is also frozen so i don't even know
what it looks like right now i don't even know my obs is
actually windows the preview stuff is like frozen so like i
don't even know what it looks like at the moment okay I'm
just gonna assume I'm back up I'm gonna assume am I am on
the screen guys am I on this oh that's not okay if that's
not what I wanted extra light okay all right this one this
is the right one I think yeah there we go I had to look at
my youtube preview we're fine everything's fine all right
here we go we're back we're back how do i kill joker please
oh god please we need to get me out of here get me out of
here Ow!
I wasn't looking!
It's okay, we're fine.
We're back.
Use the bat claw.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
I have to use the bat claw.
For my pure intuition, I figured out how to kill Joker.
Aw, this is me.
What?
Oh.
Nice, I got him.
I did it all by myself.
Get down!
My natural intuition.
Without looking at chat.
Boom, boom.
That's fucking right.
You're never gonna get out of this.
What?
Ooh.
Ow.
Okay, can I run away from this?
What if I just...
Alright, round two.
Oh my god, it's like Mario!
Three hits and you're out!
Okay, what if I...
I have three battle rides right now.
Alright, nice.
Oh shit!
Nice.
We're fine, we're fine.
Everything is fine.
I'm doing all the combos necessary.
Boop!
Okay.
Look at that.
I'm comboing!
Finally!
It took me the rest of this game to learn how to combo!
Oh god.
Maybe my...
Yes.
Okay.
I just need to bait these guys to kill him.
Oh shit.
Nope.
No knife.
It's alright.
We're good.
We just have to keep...
We just gotta have to make sure we don't get hit.
Everything will be fine.
all right nice explode hold down just don't hit me no I'm so
close no why did you come down it's not fair it should be
like a magical We're all cutscene where nothing interrupts
me when I transform into a magical girl, but instead nobody
interrupts me when I fucking try to kill Joker.
There's no etiquette.
I can't believe it.
Alright.
It's okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Where is the etiquette?
You're supposed to not touch somebody when they're doing the
cutscene.
No, it's like when you're in a cutscene, you don't interrupt
him.
That's always the rule.
I'm going to explode.
Please.
No!
So close!
Stop!
This is not fair.
This boss fight fucking sucks.
I can't believe it.
Why does it take so long?
Batman, why don't you have better upper body strength?
I don't understand.
Why?
Why are you not jacked enough?
Okay, here we go.
Jack Rider!
Can you hear me?
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
We got it!
Here we go.
Batman, you could have made more antidotes!
Alright, nice.
Alright, one more.
We just need one more.
And then we should be fine.
Can I just run away?
There's no way.
I understand now.
Never dodge, bro.
Just run.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Last one.
There's no way I can get distracted this time.
As long as I keep...
As long as I keep throwing my punch.
Ow.
Oh no.
Oh no, he has guns.
No!
Why are you letting them have guns now?
This is not fair!
Okay.
Alright, get rid of him.
Oh, God.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get the gun away.
No guns.
No guns allowed.
Mele's only.
Okay.
I gotta get rid of him.
I don't like... I don't like the fucking...
Okay, I'm gonna hope the bombs will kill them for me.
Okay.
God damn it.
There's so many.
Oh!
Who has the gun?
How did you get the gun?
Oh shit.
How do you get a gun?
Where did you get that?
Alright.
I gotta make sure.
Trigger.
Nice.
Okay.
Why?
Dodge.
God.
No wonder.
No wonder everyone was like, this is the worst one.
No wonder everyone's like, this is the worst boss.
But I agree.
I fucking agree.
This is the worst.
Worst boss fight.
Jesus Christ.
Got that.
Then.
Get closer.
No!
It's not close enough!
Please.
Jump.
Okay.
Thank God.
No, no, no!
Not the gun!
Alright.
Okay, we got rid of the gun.
Yes!
No!
Nice!
Please don't take a bolster!
No!
No no no no no!
Fuck you!
No!
Nobody died!
How did you live?
Who let you live?
Okay.
There we go.
We should be fine.
Please, please, do not get close to me.
Please.
Oh, my God.
How do they keep coming back?
It's just, it's always the one guy.
Why is it always the one guy?
No, no.
Okay, goodbye.
It's always the one.
guy okay there's no way I can get interrupted now it's
always you I always keep getting one guide like how is this
possible how is it always one I don't to understand okay
there's no way okay no no no no no no no no no one shot no
okay we gotta get rid of all three i don't trust all of
these guys okay there's no way there's no there is a way
Oh my god I don't know how this keeps happening to me I this
is actually like impressive I I can't even you know what
this is actually pretty impressive now it's oh god I'm sorry
Gordon I keep getting
I'm sorry Gordon I don't know how this keeps happening
There's no way there's no way No Tonight Gotham I have
defeated your dear dark night He's still alive!
Let's get ready!
He's still alive!
Why is it always one guy?
How is this possible?
How is it always one person that was alive?
How?
I thought they were all dead!
There's no fucking way!
I'm actually so unlucky.
I've never been so unlucky before.
Oh my god.
Do you think everyone's dead except for one?
Except for one!
That's actually so unlucky.
Get out!
Alright.
Explode.
There's...
i can't believe it i would think that they're dead but then
they keep coming back they keep coming back it never stopped
are you all down are you all down for once oh my god finally
i didn't think you were gonna give this shit something glad
so thank you for the super chat thank you thank you how have
i got such a dumb bird brain as my Ochi.
How is I supposed to know that one guy?
This has nothing to do with luck.
I thought he was dead.
Alright, here we go.
We're fine.
This time.
It's fine.
I'll double tap for real, guys.
Don't worry.
I'll double tap this time.
I swear Don't worry guys I'll double tap Trust I've learned
my lesson Chad learned my lesson Alright Now I know what to
do Nice okay got it I got it Do what?
I totally dodged it I 100% dodged that I swear I Okay.
All right.
They're all dead.
I won't get one guy this time.
See?
I'm learning.
I told you guys.
I told you guys I can learn.
Why do you let Matt hit him?
Is he stupid?
I'm double tapping.
There you go.
See, I told you I could learn.
I told you guys.
Alright, let me get rid of these guys.
Dodge.
Counter.
Alright, throw.
Can I throw them, actually?
Oh my god!
Look!
I have a critical hit!
I'm comboing!
14!
Ow.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
All right.
We're fine.
Okay, we gotta get...
Oh, shit.
Not the guns.
Not the gun.
Okay, we gotta get rid of him.
And then punch him in the back.
Okay, I'm gonna get hit at him.
Oh.
God, there's still so many!
No, he's going for the gun!
Okay.
George, don't gun for you!
Is he okay?
As long as there's...
As long as like he doesn't get the gun, we're fine.
I just hope he... I just wanted him to not hold the gun.
Alright.
How many more are there?
Okay.
Last guy.
Alright.
Nice!
I told you I can learn.
I double tap for real.
I can take it.
I can take anything you throw at me, Bats.
I did it.
I'm actually going to win.
Ready for the next round?
Always.
What?
I'll never let you win.
Maybe he just...
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
That's like a broken hand right there.
Like, he literally put explosives on his hand.
Like, what the fuck?
Holy fuck.
Yeah, sorry, Barbara.
I sort of...
He got electrocuted several times.
Because I kept getting one guide.
All super criminals are back in custody.
Quite a mess in there.
And the venom-enhanced inmates are returning to normal.
But what about the bones?
I'll survive.
See you tonight, Barbara.
Shame about your car.
This is a break damage, Barbara.
Thanks, Jim.
But I have one on the way.
Get some rest.
You deserve it.
Stay safe, Jim.
Two officers down.
The suspect is fleeing in their patrol car.
Yeah, his arm is his hand is definitely broken.
Holy fuck.
We did it!
We beat Batman!
Wait!
I could have beat this game!
I could have beat this game two days ago in part three!
You guys were like, oh, it's gonna take her like two to
three more hours.
Like three more hours.
I could have literally played an hour and we could have just
beat the game two days ago.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it What do you mean it almost took
me two hours It took me an hour We had like 5-20 minutes of
Zaxx and Donning in the beginning
I can't believe I let you guys baited me into doing Part 4
Holy shit This game fucking Oh my god see was fucking crying
while playing this game.
Anyway, now that I've finished Batman, the next long game,
the next series, playthrough I'm gonna do is Resident Evil
4.
Finally.
I cannot wait to do the escort missions again.
The remastered slash remake.
We're gonna do Resident Evil 4 for next week, our new
playthrough.
Oh my god, I wrote down like a shitload of games.
Is that the same fucking picture of Batman beating up a guy
again?
I swear, I just saw this.
Also, Taurus, thank you for that vibe.
Get the ships.
Thank you.
Um, I was like, I was writing, like, a bunch of games and
stuff that I want to do.
Um, uh, that I want to play now that I can play as an indie.
Oh my God.
Okay, wait, let me... Okay, we don't care about the credits
anyway.
Let me,
let me look at it.
Alright, I actually made a little games list too.
Okay, there's like, let's see.
I have Freddy Fish, God of War, Shadow of Colossus, Monster
Ranch, Club Penguin, Digimon World, the Batman Telltale
series.
Oh my God, I'm planning on trying to buy the Minecraft
Telltale series on like, do they have the Minecraft Telltale
series on the Xbox?
Do they have it on the PlayStation, or is it an Xbox
exclusive?
Because then I need to buy an Xbox.
I need to buy an Xbox.
Is the Minecraft Telltale Series only on Xbox?
Because you can't get it online anymore.
You have to, yeah, the story mode.
The Minecraft story mode.
Because, like, I need to buy an Xbox then.
Oh, it has a PlayStation?
Okay.
hard copy of the minecraft story mode because it's so i'm
never like i've never like played it before but i've seen
like videos of the of the pig dying okay have you guys it's
on netflix well you can you watch that but you can do it you
can play in a minecraft telltale series on the playstation
it's unavailable you can't you can't like buy it you can't
buy a digital copy of it anymore you have to like buy the
hard copy because it's like um it's like it's like what's
the word they like took it out because they want to pretend
it doesn't exist they they want to pretend they never made a
minecraft story game um so if it's on the okay so for those
who don't know There's like an infamous scene where of the
pig dying.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
It's so fucking funny.
It's actually...
I mean, we don't need to watch the credits.
Okay, let's skip the credits.
Let's skip.
Is there an after credit scene?
Oh, there is an after credit scene.
It's so good.
I want to like live through that.
What's this?
Oh my god, scarecrow.
He's alive?
Who is that?
It's as if he never died.
Alright.
all right let me i need to show you guys i need to show okay
let me get rid of this all unsafe yes i already finished the
game anyway okay minecraft pig um story mode it's so good
look at wait is this one okay wait minecraft story mode
rubin's death all right here It's so fucking funny.
Okay, okay, this is what I'm talking about.
But, like, I want to play the Minecraft story mode because
of this scene where the pig fucking dies.
Because it's supposed to be, like, super fucking sad.
And then he dies.
And then he turns into fucking pork.
Ruben!
I don't know who you are!
Don't keep these spoilers.
This is the only thing I'll spoil because it's so fucking
funny.
It turns into fucking pork.
Like, what the fuck?
Holy shit.
I remember thinking that was sad.
just a floating pork anyway i want to rubin will be
remembered oh my god he just picks up the pork chop what the
he's just picking up the pork chop anyway i really want to
play in minecraft story mode um other okay so yeah like i
said i wrote down like all these games i want to play so
like another one was disney dreamlight valley which was the
uh which is like basically the animal crossing Microsoft
Flight Simulator, Train Simulator, DuckTales Remastered,
Dead Rising.
Okay, I've always wanted to try out Dead Rising.
I think Dead Rising would be really fun.
Crash Bandicoot Trilogy and Racing, Tokyo Jungle, Sleeping
Dogs, the original Kingdom Hearts, Halo Infinite, or like
anything from Halo, Sunset Overdrive, and then I was
watching Shore 4 play like Supermarket Simulator, and then I
was like, you know what, I want to know what it's like to be
Minimum wage.
I was watching ShareForeplay Supermarket Simulator for like,
like I wasn't watching for seven hours.
I watched like the last two hours of it.
And it's like that type of game where like you just turn off
your brain and just like, turn off your brain and restock.
Anyway.
Kyle, thank you.
Thank you.
GoKeyersey's PlayStation like Metal Gear.
Let's super chat.
Thank you.
Dark Hunter.
Tey-doki meant to become a member on my birthday this past
Saturday, but better late than never, eh?
Love you and all the things you do.
Great stream so far.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you guys have been enjoying it.
Uh, but yeah, there's like, I've been like slowly writing
down all the games that I've wanted to play, uh, that I've
been wanting to play, like the past couple of years.
So, like, I'm, I'm like super excited to like, try, like,
eventually do everything on this this there's like oh my god
i love how like people were like when they saw the sonic
game that put for this week people were like oh my god she's
funny she's gonna be playing sonic and then they read which
type of sonic i'm gonna be playing and everyone was like oh
it's that sonic game
that's so funny people were like oh no the monkey paw is
like to play sonic it's sonic dreams collection
Pikachu thank you for the 50 gifted ships thank you thank
you I really appreciate it thank you so much um all you
zoomers and and uh gen a you guys were not you guys never
lived until you saw sonic dreams collection which is in my
opinion one of the Sonic games out there.
I've never played Sonic Dreams Collection before.
I remember when it first came out and I seen like a
playthrough of it.
And honestly, in my opinion, definitely one of the best
Sonic games out there.
Did you guys know that the creators of Sonic Dream
Collection went on to create Neon White?
I think that's actually crazy that the creator of Sonic
Dreams Collection neon white.
Like the jump between that to this was the origin story.
The origin story of the devs of neon white.
That's so that's insane.
And also Tattletal, Tattal, Tattal, like the indie horror
game, indie mascot horror game.
Let's see.
D-Dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Does somebody say Crash Team Racing?
I remember I talked about it before, but I think is one of
the best uh one of the best uh racing games out there i like
that more than mario cart i i enjoy a crash uh crash batting
kit racing more than mario cart uh yeah thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you kaito thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you we finished our first game we finished our first series
i'm so happy uh i'm so happy our first series that we
finished was Batman.
Aypen, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
It was my birthday yesterday.
Thank you for being there and making me laugh for another
year while I get old.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday.
Happy belated birthday to you.
Happy belated birthday, dear.
Aypen, happy belated birthday to you.
Yeah!
Also, Liam, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
It's one of the best Sonic games, in my opinion.
I never played it.
Never changed.
Shogi.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
It's no problem, guys.
I still think it's one of the best Sonic games out there.
That's why you know it's good.
I've never played it, but I think it's the best one.
That's when you know it's a really good Sonic game.
You don't have to play it to know it's peak Sonic.
Um, Nexie, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Super excited for you and all the fun games you have
planned.
Congrats on finishing your first series.
Thank you.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you guys Yeah This was a very short stream.
Um, I legitimately thought it would be a lot longer.
I mean to be fair Uh, to be fair like I did I feel like I
was going my PC was going through a lot like the last like
uh two days ago It's going through a lot.
I was on fucking wi-fi and like My crashes was insane.
But, like, yeah, we made it through.
We powered through, guys.
We powered through.
Guys, I swear it's not a PC.
Okay, maybe it's a little bit of a PC issue, okay?
But, like, I swear, guys, it's not just my PC, though.
It can't just be my PC.
There was more at stake with the game.
Anyway, I actually have a lot of behind-the-scenes work to
do today, so I'm going to call it here.
I really want to do it long as that's done, but I have,
like, a huge list of stuff to do for work today, because,
like, it's never over.
Work is never over.
There's so many adult things to do.
Oh, my God.
Me and Mr. Man were talking about, like, payroll, and, like,
we were, like, negotiating pays, salaries and stuff and I
was just like Oh my god I had to open Another thing I was
like there's so Much work to do I just want to stream Batman
and be A silly anime girl That's all I want To do but I Have
to I have I have to do so much adult Things
Anyway, AeroBornNinja, thank you for the super chat, thank
you, thank you.
DokiBirds suffering from success, thank you for the super
chat, thank you, thank you.
Work is never over.
Anyway, I'm going to call it here, guys.
Thank you, everybody, for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up
and move around to get that blood flowing.
Any of you, say that for me, head to bed, because you
deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!